well here's another thing that we cannot
wait for the inside of the Brady Bunch
home becoming a reality HGTV is making
it all happen look at them all there
together it's there a big that happen
with the help of the original Brady kids
as you see and only our nischelle Turner
was there as Barry Williams got to work
hi this is Barry Williams aka Greg Brady
I am right in front of the Brady Bunch
house the real Brady Bunch house I love
social media and I want to go viral
Barry's all in for this very Brady
renovation
his assigned part of the house Greg's
groovy attic tell me this what
significance did the Attic hold for
install for me it was everything you
knows it was freedom it was my own
private space I got to get away from my
little brothers I wasn't next door to my
sister yeah I could have my own wife and
privacy Plus this was the place where I
got to hide the goat rat Khalid go who
is the mascot ate my tennis shoes at my
term-paper what do you plan him for
desert my mattress there's just one
problem
there's no attic in the real life Brady
house a solution the basement HGTV stars
Lara Spencer and Jasmine Roth or helping
Greg make it happen the reason we had to
go down into the basement is because we
wanted you to be able to look at the
front of the house and not ruin the
roofline right right so we couldn't go
any higher you so we had no choice but
to kind of dig down we're going to have
a faux window with a tree cool the only
difference is the staircase will go down
it's pretty amazing yeah well they they
said you've been the worker bee that
you're not playing around
no here and we get to do everything they
encourage it to if you offer to help I'm
gonna put you to work
don't play with my skills why is the
shell trying to move in with the Bradys
see stop that now a very Brady
renovation premieres this fall in HGTV
you
[Music]